und zwar sieht ohne tatsächlich ein
gegner in unmittelbarer nähe ist extrem
aufgeregt service escape und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft waro kommentare heute mit den
drei folgenden teams wir haben einmal
ausschnitt die haben es zum dritten mal
schon in die folgen geschafft wir haben
team technik das sind nach epe mit kev
und spark of phoenix und wir haben team
und fans war also um gespielt und felsen
hd ich kann euch gleich sagen dass es
heute richtig zur sache ging
es gab einige kämpfe kampfsituationen
irgendetwas in richtung wassers ist
werdet ihr sehen ich würde sagen wir
legen mal mit timo steht los ist es
richtig selbst habe übrigens ich kann
wenn ich nach kommentieren überhaupt
nicht atmen das ist irgendwie das ist
ein anderer atmosphäre wenn ich nach
kommentieren wenn ich spiele ist alles
cool so pi pa po aber nicht nach
kommentiere habe ich richtige art und
probleme nehmen übrigens heute mit maxis
micro 4
der hat mein mikro ist sie sich
ausgeliehen
ihr biss ist gar ein bisschen
umgestürzte deswegen ist die audio
vielleicht nicht so wie sonst sollten
ordnung sein
lasst uns loslegen team aus steht okay
gut aussieht haben in ihrer heutigen
folge dass die folge 6 nicht in ihrer
folge sondern vor ihrer folge
tatsächlich intendanten vier stunden
gekämpft um jemanden zu schneiden wer
diese person ist dieses leighton wollten
kann ich euch mal sagen denke ich es
heute nicht zu viel sein und zwar ist
der gute esi der als irgendwie geschafft
ins zielfernrohr von die badi stocken zu
geraten von team aus it und den haben
wir ja heute versuchte wegzuhauen das
hat gewissermaßen konsequenzen bzw es
war eher so dass die buddys zocken davor
schon versucht haben sie zusammen als
sie sich die koordinaten von dem
rausgesucht haben dessen koordinaten da
haben wir schon mal gesagt allerdings
war es beim letzten mal nicht
erfolgreich und jetzt quasi beim zweiten
versuch haben sie sich echt vier stunden
vom pc verkehrt um auf ihn zu warten ist
von erfolg gekrönt war seht ihr mit dem
ersten link in der folge davor sei er
immer noch bzw
ebenfalls in der folge haben sie noch
nach lapis lazuli gesucht es ist alles
ist schrecklich es geht gar nicht
der 8er lapislazuli da hat mir der
letzten folge so ein bisschen
durcheinander und zwar ich habe sehr
widersprüchlich die quellen ich hab ne
für quelle gefunden die behauptet hat
dass man lapislazuli nur auf höhe für
das bis 11 finden kann
dann gab es wiederum andere quellen die
gesagt haben man kann die abhör 31
abwärts finden das war auch die quelle
die die buddys talk verwendet haben sie
haben dann tatsächlich in ihrer folge
noch leblos gefunden und zwar auf höhe
17 damit ist meine behauptung aus der
letzten folge revidierte ist falsch
falsifiziert man kann es auch außerhalb
der schichten fünf bis elf finden
scheinbar von 31 abwärts und die
schichten um am häufigsten findet sind
wohl die schichten 13 und 16
das problem ist jetzt mit dem
hauptmieter sie nur noch haupt noch von
den barocken der lebt der hat wirklich
wirklich schlechtes equipment für die
sechste folge das kann man glaube ich
schon so sagen also die da ist auf jeden
fall im unteren drittel würde ich sagen
muss sein argument er sollte da
vielleicht ein bisschen gas geben sonst
wenn er selbst an irgendwie überrascht
was unwahrscheinlich ist weil er mal rum
läuft aber wenn er mal jemanden trifft
da ein problem weil ich tablett voller
erschwert es nicht so doll
da sollte wissen was mache allerdings
hatte das ja nur deswegen weil er viele
viele slapping versuche gemacht habt ihr
vielleicht heute von erfolg gekrönt sind
wie gesagt erst lenkt das muss man das
finde ich aber gut das muss man loben
und das dafür zieht nach sich dass man
nicht so gutes equipment hat okay dann
kommen wir mal zu team technik da ging
es heute auch richtig rund die sind
tatsächlich auch auf gegner getroffen
und zwar sieht das wie folgt aus die
jungs loggen sich ein nicken bauen sich
da aus ihrem loch irgendwie hoch und
eine minute später oder sogar noch
unternehmen oder später den zander und
weiß weiß nach und sondern auch wirklich
nach die wolken die scheinbar
wegklatschen
ja und dann geht's rund meine meinung
ist dass man in der situation
man war wie ihr wisst natürlich nicht
wer es geschafft hat wenig wenn ihr das
wie noch nicht gesehen hat der situation
hätte man
den höhen vorteil bisschen besser nutzen
können um die gegner darunter zuschlagen
werden die haben da so ein bisschen um
ein loch herum getanzt das seht ihr auch
ein team hätte da den höhen vorteil gut
nutzen können glaube ich um den jahres
andere team oder zu schlagen
die waren aber glaube ich zu aufgeregt
allerdings hatte auch ein team
deutlichen equipment nachteil würde ich
sagen weil es andere themen wirklich
wirklich gut war dann kommen wir jetzt
abschließend zu übrigens link nummer
zwei führt zum kampf den sollte man sich
unbedingt anschauen da ging es richtig
rund
dann kommen wir an dritter stelle zu
team unfassbar unfassbar die haben ihre
folge damit begonnen dass sie sich im
dorf eingeloggt haben liefern so ein
bisschen herum dann auf einmal geht es
rund und zwar sieht ohne tatsächlich ein
gegner in unmittelbarer nähe ist extrem
aufgeregt rentner zurück
die treffen sich sind ja vor lauter
hektik halten sich dann relativ lang auf
und dann machen sie sich auf die jagd
nach dem gegner welche gegner das ist
und ob es vielleicht ein ganzes team ist
seht ihr mit dem dritten link da geht es
dann ein bisschen mehr und ich finde
allerdings was simon da deutlich
aggressiver hätte drauf gehen können
also hätte wirklich gleich als er die
gesehen hat oder ihn gesehen hat er
sofort drauf gehen müssen um die quali
zu quetschen
auch wenn es jetzt gegen die intuition
geht immer so aufgeregt deswegen kann
ich mache mir auch keinen vorwurf
sondern im nachhinein betrachtet wäre es
fairer gewesen hinzugehen und quasi das
mit dass sie an einem hinterherlaufen
sich dann mit felsen zu treffen
allerdings muss man auch sagen dass
simon nicht so gutes equipment hatte
allerdings den gegner den er da gesehen
hat auch nicht wie man glaube ich
ungefähr equipment er ist dann halt
einfach der hektik in dem moment
geschuldet glaube ich also meine meinung
ist man hätte da durchaus einen kampf
wagen können im nachhinein das war's von
heutigen folge waren kommentare heute
etwas kürzer das ließ sich alles gute
kompakt kommentieren
seit so gut und check unbedingt die
links in der beschreibung ab wenn ihr
sehen wollt was da genau passiert ist
und lasst auch sehr gerne ein wort für
den essens ist aber es dürfte der ersten
in der beschreibung sein
das wollte noch vor bis zum zwölften
achten und wenn das klappt dann können
wir vielleicht bis nein lieferanten
starten gehen vereinten kennt er die
united